Girl 1: A museum to me is a place of expression.
Boy: MoMA is one of those places where art
can mean pretty much anything.
Girl 2: MoMA for me is a home.
Man 1: Where every idea is accepted.
Woman 1: You could be moved.
You could be surprised.
Woman 2: Everybody should have a MoMA.
It's nurturing.
It's welcoming.
Man 2: In 2019, MoMA will be explosive.
Ana: The new performance space will be the
integral part of the collection galleries.
Lana: We are constantly challenging ourselves.
Woman 1: It's a living, breathing collection.
We can remix it so that it's responding to
the world around us.
Glenn: Putting works of art in conversation
with each other in ways that have not happened
before here.
Paola: It's tremendously exciting.
We're just at the beginning.
Glenn: In 2019, MoMA will be exhilarating.
I'll just leave it at that.